when was the moment where you thought
i'm not really on board with this train
when they told me i had to suck dick
honestly it was that simple for me who
told you to suck dick a lot of people
a lot of a lot of people claiming to be
lesbians
because they were trans act because they
were trans-inclusive lesbians
like that was like the moment where i
was like okay this is just homophobia
and it's fine like how did we get here
how did how are supposed
these supposed people that are queer
activists
literally against what homosexuality is
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant and returning guest
is a fellow youtuber arielle scarcella
welcome back to trigonometry well i mean
well welcome yeah welcome to england yes
thank you for welcoming me it's great to
have you here first time with me in
person we interviewed you during one of
the lockdowns ages ago i think you
interviewed me like a month after i came
out of the closet as as like a
non-leftist really that's apparently
what you said in like 2020 that's like
right when i came out as of as as
leaving the left right right so that's
that must have been how you found me
that's how everybody else found me i
think so yeah a lot of people
recommended that we speak with you and
we had a conversation but remote is not
the same as in person so uh just for
anyone who didn't catch that interview
who are you what has been your journey
through life uh what leads you to be
sitting here talking to us oh my god
this is it's a lot
it's a lot let's be real
i'm like the og lesbian of youtube right
like i've been doing videos for 12 years
uh-huh and in the beginning it was like
it's okay to be gay
like that was like back in the day right
like 2008 9 10 11 when it sort of needed
to be said a little bit right we didn't
even have gay marriage in the united
states right so that was
it was actually oppression right there
was actual oppression there now
everyone's gay now everyone's getting
now everyone's non-binary
like what even is that so then i started
talking about sex ed and then i was like
okay i'm just getting sick of
these crazy people calling themselves
queer non-binary when they don't have
gender dysphoria
when they're not same-sex attracted when
i know
you know can i i could curse on here
like i know that you're a lesbian you
wouldn't suck a dick
like
and and people are feeling there's a lot
of straight women who wouldn't do that
either but that's not enough about my
marriage problems anyway oh my god
so but yeah like it became
such
all the words and all the identities
used to mean so many different things
than they do now yeah and then i started
it's like i
reverted back to the old thing it's okay
to be a homosexual again
like that's where i'm at now and i talk
about culture and politics and
that stuff so that's where i'm at now
because now you can't be can't be gay
anymore it's transphobic you know of
course so oh what is it let's get into
that yeah we could go here dive right in
let's dive right into that so what do
you mean by that well i don't i what do
i mean what do they mean okay and i mean
pun intended day the days
the days we call them the day thems
right it's like you can't you can't be
like a straight-up lesbian anymore why
not because they call you transphobic if
you'd like your eyes i'm a lesbian that
like i only want like vagina sorry oh
you're transphobic because some trans
women have penises and some trans women
are women and some trans women are
lesbians and you need to like it's like
no
it's not how it works but
so you're saying being attracted to the
same sex in your case the female sex
yeah is considered exclusionary by trans
activists 100 and a lot of them are here
in in the uk
just saying
i'm just saying
it's like the united states the uk and
australia it's like and canada it's bad
well that's fair really governmental at
once i mean it's first world countries
yeah first world problems right right
right you don't see people in africa
complaining about like homosexuality
directing this episode is going to be
demonetised
so i guess but being serious for a
second what you're saying is you are now
seeing that people like you who identify
who identify who are lesbians right
right
you're sort of you're feeling pressure
100
and i get messages every day
literally every day people that i date
like it's funny because like when i'm
when i go on dates and they find out
like who i am whatever they'll be like a
lot of them will be like oh you must
have girls up in your dms flirting with
you i'm like actually it's just it's a
lot of like gay people that are like
you know i'm outcasted at my school
because i'm like homosexual and i'm not
non-binary and not queer and i'm not you
know trans identifying and i'm not open
to everything it's like because you're
just gay like so you're not rainbow
enough anymore you're not rainbow enough
you can't you can't just be like a basic
gay guy or a basic lesbian anymore is it
because you know why though right no
ghostly why because you because nobody
likes cis straight white people right
or cis like the the less
let me tell you this how does that how
do you say it okay so like cis straight
white men are at the bottom of the pole
like they're at the top of the world we
know yeah so right
top of the world but like in the in like
the gay culture right like or the woe
culture you're at the bottom like nobody
likes you yeah so like then you're
you could be white
uh you could be a white cis
but gay man right and then you can be
white says
lesbian yeah and then it's like the
queers
trans black trans women black trans
women at the top right like we have to
praise these people we're just all the
[ __ ] same yeah like we're all on the
same level we're all learning about
ourselves we're all different people
nobody has to hate anybody like this has
to they're trying to erase hierarchy and
the system of oppressions by creating
another system of oppression hating
white people hating straight people
hating men
it doesn't make any sense so now you
have all these young kids that are cis
straight white men or cis straight white
women
that are claiming all these other
identities
because they don't want to be on the
bottom of the pole right they don't want
to be hated so they're like just kidding
i'm not actually white i'm native
american like elizabeth warren
like i'm just kidding i'm not i'm
actually non-binary so i'm like i get
like oppression points now i'm up here
this is what happens
you created a new system of hierarchy
stupid
yeah like they they created what they
tried when we're trying to erase
it's it's a really good point what does
queer mean ariel but i don't even know i
literally i'm gay and i don't even know
the word queer means anymore because i
think i think no no because because
queer
came around in the in the 50s and there
was a type of and there was a genre of
theater and literature called queer
theater queer literature which was
normally gay men and some gay women
talking about their experiences of what
it was like to live in that time where
your identity and your sexual identity
was illegal
yeah
and that's what a lot of that literature
was about and it's very interesting
and and it has real power to it
what does queer mean now
i think queer people use it what i think
it should mean
is anyone that's gender dysphoric
or anyone that's same sex attracted
even though i hate the word but i would
be okay with other people using the word
for that for that purpose what i think
it actually means now the way people use
it is anything other than cis straight
white man
or cis straight white woman
like you color your hair you queer
like you have a nose ring like in a like
a like a septum piercing and like a
little bit different haircut you cut
your hair on the side you queer
even though you like only like a woman
that sleeps with like men you know i
think to some people who are coming
everyone wants to be in this you know i
know i know exactly what i mean and i
think there's some people coming to this
whole thing from for like the first time
or who are like not on the internet they
think that we're crazy right like oh
you're over exaggerating it's like
actually and i sometimes think that we
are over exaggerating but we did a live
show here in london
and one of the bar stuff who was very
nice she was she was i say she she ident
we don't know what her identity [ __ ] me
this is difficult
this person i'm talking about was
non-binary
and when one of our team talked to her
just as a as a friendly chat she
basically went you know i thought you
guys were like these evil bigots
whatever then i watched the show and you
you're cool and also she said
she
well with some non-binary people go away
girl go by she pronouns it's a girl i'm
sorry it was a girl so these pronouns it
was it was a girl but like blair said
like they trade them like pokemon cards
pronouns you have one i have one this
one i swear to god this is so [ __ ]
like it's so stupid right anyway so this
was someone who was born female
identified as non-binary and what she
said was look
i've grown up in a society where
women are quote unquote disadvantaged
and oppressed right yep and this is a
way for me
to opt out
of this category but that's not true
because you go to go to the middle east
you can't opt out of being female
but in this society she can right which
is the actual privilege
but this isn't isn't
so stupid and they claim everyone else
has privilege [ __ ] go to the middle
east they'll throw you off the building
for being gay
like lit like it's it's it's definitely
getting demonetized
yeah i think so i think that last little
comment just just please there's nothing
we don't know
[ __ ] it we can make it we don't give a
[ __ ] we've been monetized we just find
it funny we just laugh at youtube's
rules about this because we're trying to
have an honest conversation and you
can't but
that's what we're trying to do um but i
guess where i'm going with it is like i
think
you you're right about the totem pole of
different level like people just want to
be in a different place on that pole yes
you know
and and i think it seems that when you
took like it sounds like something
people who are bigots would make up
about people who are just identifying as
a different gender but they're actually
doing it it's not made up like we're not
making this up right no this is an
actual thing that's happening like
everywhere
that's first world countries yeah yeah
but you know the thing that actually
makes
crystallizes what we're talking about
are the flags have you seen the flags
this is beautiful
like i don't even i'm i'm gay and i
can't even
i think i know about six of them do you
know what the straight flag is
no it's beige
beige
there's a straight flag now and it's
based
and i'm sure you guys get [ __ ] for that
probably like if you had it you know you
don't have one
right if you did
you would get [ __ ] for it yeah yeah yeah
because that would be straight pride
wouldn't it right right and straight is
bad you can't be straight you can't be
practical yeah
but it's so interesting it to me that is
the most beautiful troll i've ever seen
in my life yeah you get a flag but it's
beige because you're [ __ ] boring
that's true that's exactly what it is
yeah yeah so is this what you talk about
now
on the youtube channel i talk about i
mean i dove into politics for a little
bit but like that gets me demonetized
and it's also very very difficult to
talk about right because like
nobody really knows who's lying in
politics like everybody lies it's
politics so i try to stick to more
culture-based stuff
and it just happens right now people can
call me transphobic for it but like
this is a women's rights issue and i've
always been an actual like a traditional
feminist not like these crazy ones
right but traditional feminists like
men and women should be treated for the
most part in general as equals
traditional feminist kind of stuff my
body my choice i am pro-choice i'm
always gonna be pro-choice not that i
think killing babies is good it's a lot
like i said it's a big conversation but
yeah that's
more of where i'm going now it's not
much much about politics unless unless
there's like a gay rights issue in
politics at the moment then i'll talk
about it right now it's it's a lot about
women's rights
because you have leah thomas
looking like a straight-up dude like i
believe i do believe this person is a
trans woman probably i mean she does
seem like an actual trans person
but it doesn't mean that it's fair
right
you can be
they could be two things two things can
be true at once right somebody can be
trans but doesn't mean they're entitled
to compete with women right two things
can be true at once exactly but the left
can't see it that way
it's like it's black very black and
white which is kind of weird right
because they're not
they're like anti-racist they don't see
color it's like
i don't know it's it's a really good
point
particularly thomas you know we have a
lot of people on to discuss this
particular issue yeah and this is a
question that i ask of
a few of our guests but the first people
to really start talking about this were
gay women i remember a friend of mine
who she was talking about this kind of
stuff in 2014 in 20 wow that's
yeah cause she she she goes to all
female sex clubs and she would go there
and participate that sounds so old
participating old and boring
you know my little flag outside down
with this sort of thing no and she was
saying that she's
a troll thing
i can't and so she would be there and
and there would be basically a dude
would walk in wearing a dress
yeah and they'd be like you're a dude in
a dress which is not a trans woman by
the way yeah right and he'd be like well
i identify as female and this was like
2014 2016. well i said that didn't
happen in new york back then there was
one person
but uh i think her name was joanne
and she was she was i think i don't
think she was a crush i don't think she
was trans i think she was a
cross-dresser yeah but she never made us
feel uncomfortable never and we accepted
her we were like this was like 2014
2015. like she came to the gay club the
lesbian club never hit on anybody
because she's not trans woman she's just
a dude that likes wearing dresses fine
yeah we didn't care but there's a that's
the difference right yeah you like
feeling entitled to a space versus
knowing that you're a guest
in the space i know that sounds like a
very woke thing to say but it's it's
true in some cases right they can't just
like walk into
like a man like a men's bath house as a
woman like that's
it's weird like you can it's just like
that's a men's space right
she didn't do that so we didn't care if
she was trans or just a simple
cross-dresser she just hung out and just
acted like any of the other girls never
hit on us never like made us feel
uncomfortable that's the difference but
you're a dude in a dress and then you're
like hitting on girls and like being if
that's i'm assuming that's probably what
was
that's disrespectful yeah like you're
clearly a dude in a dress or a
cross-dresser whatever you want to call
it and you're impeding on women's spaces
so one place we have there's like
there's like five lesbian bars left in
the united states you really have to
come to our bar like go away but i think
that's kind of the point isn't it
because we've all got which is a very
male thing to do by the way
no no offense like no no no no no no
yeah yeah see this is why i i kind of
miss the old days of comedy because in
some ways like we being comedians you
could take the piss out of men and women
and that was and you just treat like men
are different to women men are stupid in
many ways women do things and you know
women are sneaky in many ways right yeah
we just we're just different yeah and
like but but now you can't you can't
really address that
without becoming some kind of evil
because gender is beta right
um but i think one of the points you hit
on actually is really important which is
the sort of like every group now we
don't we're not trying to
like make people's lives easier or like
just just like go oh this person is a
bit different let's include them if we
can it's more like this is my [ __ ]
right i deserve to be here right
and that's not how gay people never
that's not how gay people won their
rights by the way like it's different at
stonewall yes stonewall they acted like
that because they were getting beaten up
yeah yeah that's a different scenario
but gay people were like we're just like
you we just want something a little
different but we want to interact with
society and be a part of society like
everyone else that's not what this new
movement's about it's the opposite it's
literally the opposite like what you're
saying
you you have to conform to what we think
about ourselves
is the opposite of what gay people did
which is we're going to conform to you
we're just a little different
i mean that's why that's why the yeah no
no no go ahead finish no i was going to
say that's why i think that's why trans
rights is the tr not actual trans people
by the way i don't think this is just
like these non-binary queer people
that's why it's reversing our rights
that's why
a lot of these a lot of these issues are
going backwards
how so
a lot of it just like the the trans
rights specifically i would say well how
well maybe not not the rights
necessarily i would say the
acceptance of us well there's data to
show that yes yes right yesterday to
show that people like
less and less accepting of lgbt people
over the last five years yeah because of
people like that like you have to see me
as i see myself that's not what self id
is
self id means self
id
if you want to be accepted into society
unfortunately this is just how it is
it's not fair maybe but it's just how
the world is like you want to be
accepted as a man you have to kind of
look like a dude like it's that simple
does everyone
get the opportunity to look like a dude
no because some people unfortunately
aren't going to be able to pass
but like make an effort and i guarantee
most people will accept you
it's these people that are entitled like
you said
but we all are we all aren't we're
annoyed like all groups now like we're
all this is the problem is all of us
have been like told you are this group
like i'm i'm supposed to go well i'm a
first generation immigrant and i love
right
what for what what's the purpose exactly
like why why do i need to identify as
part of this group and then pursue our
group rights together why can't i just
be like a person
because i think it's divided do you
think it's the divide and conquer
technique right you think that's what it
is i think that's part of it
and i think it's also i think it's also
that hierarchy thing again it's like
they don't want white people like
they're racists literally they hate
white people
they hate men they hate
white men specifically
so sorry mate yeah no but it's true
it's true like they it's and it's funny
because like i've never had an issue
with white men
like white men for the most part
are usually like well say white people
for the most part are usually the most
accepting of lgbt people i don't know if
you guys know that but if you go to like
puerto rico dominican republic mexico
they're not as like lgbt friendly there
i'm just saying black people very
christian very catholic you gotta
remember it's a thing
so
i don't know why people in the gay
community are hating white people so
much like on paper they are the most
accepting of lgbt lgbt people i think
it's maybe with within the u.s if you
look at within the u.s right it's if you
look elsewhere so you gave the example
of i mean puerto rico is part of the us
isn't it technically right
we don't like it's like a
territory yeah but like for example
where i come from russia ukraine these
aren't places that are great on lgbt
rights
i'm talking about the states yeah white
people in the states so yeah but i i
hear what you're saying right
interesting yeah yeah that's right but
but is there because this is most these
queer movements mostly in the states
right and here and here yeah yeah like
canada and i are you saying that in in
america in the in the lgbt community if
there's such a thing people are sort of
late they've embraced this idea that why
people are sort of evil like 100
they hate them and i it's sad because
like marcus and i will be walking in the
street and like he'll get looks even
because he's like he gets my friend
marcus is behind the camera right he's a
trans guy he gets [ __ ] because he's cis
passing
as a trans person like that's the point
as a trans person you want to pass
as the gender that you feel quiet and
that they give them [ __ ] for it because
they're not trans they don't care about
actual passing
so there it's just this whole movement
is everyone's speaking above everybody
else
and and feeling entitled to that space
to speak from that space when they're
not actually a part of that space
hey francis do you go on the internet to
look at naughty stuff yeah is it stuff
that you'd be embarrassed to show your
friends
yeah is it stuff that would get you
cancelled yeah well next time you decide
to be naughty and watch more
trigonometry you need to use expressvpn
it doesn't matter mate because i use
incognito mode
it doesn't matter what mode you use or
how many times you clear your browsing
history your internet service provider
can still see every single website
you've ever visited that's why even when
you're at home you should never go
online without using expressvpn my
career is finished they're there you'll
have to leave trigonometry can't be
helped anyway it doesn't matter who your
internet service provider is isps in the
us can legally sell your information to
ad companies expressvpn is an app that
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure servers so your isp
can't see the site you visit absolutely
expressvpn also keeps all of your
information secure by encrypting 100 of
your data with the most powerful
encryption available most of the time
you won't even realize you have
expressvpn on it runs seamlessly in the
background and is so easy to use all you
have to do is tap one button and you're
protected what am i gonna do
expressvpn is available on all your
devices phones computers even your smart
tv so there's no excuse for you not to
be using it go on francis do the last
bit
you don't want to end up like me protect
your online activity today
with a vpn rated number one my business
insider
visit my exclusive link
expressvpn.com
trigger and you can get an extra three
months free on a one year packet
e x p r e s s v p n dot com slash
trigger expressvpn.com
trigger to learn more
do you know what really worries me is
that
there are things that we have in place
in our society like
women's spaces
everybody understands why there's
women's spaces we all get it
we all get it particularly as a man you
you understand you know what there's a
point i want to make real quick because
i i'm gonna make it
when you were a kid i don't know if you
do this in the uk but we do this in the
united states when you were a little boy
and you were only with your mom yeah or
your aunt and you had to go to the
bathroom which bathroom they take you in
they took they took me uh i can't
remember actually okay
99 of the time they'll take you to the
women's bathroom with them yeah yeah why
is that
why is that they don't want a little boy
going in the men's room that's kind of
weird right oh it makes sense though
yeah because males are more likely to be
predators than sexual writers yeah
that's why we need women's spaces so
little boys know this at a very young
age
and the argument and also as a little
boy in a women's space you're not a
threat because you're a little boy
right yeah and the argument that i
always use when people go oh but you
know you know we should have uni six
bathrooms it's a nightclub argument
right and you will know this better than
anyone like if the gay club everyone
just uses this yes nobody cares yeah but
not my favorite thing because like the
gay dude's like [ __ ] the stalls and
i'm like all right well it's like
but you know i mean that took a detour
yeah you're giving us
an entry into no no it's brilliant into
a world with which we have no
familiarity at all
but
in a straight like nightclub let's just
call it a mainstream nightclub if a
dude's harassing you and you you make it
quite clear to him that you're not
interested for whatever reason right and
he continues to hit on you which
unfortunately is just a reality right
where do you go that's safe
in a women's face yeah yeah
and then and then the girl that's drunk
is like babe are you okay
like and then like then you're like not
up mad about that she's drunk and
helping you it's like okay
yeah yeah
but once we obliterate that
yeah there's a reason for women's spaces
like there is
and it's it's a safe it's not 99 it's a
safety issue thing yeah
i i i know people will be pissed off at
me asking this question but i'm going to
ask you anyway do you think i love it
then girl part of how we got here is
there were so parts of feminism like you
said there's different ways of doing
feminism and some of them i think are
really important and i agree with
completely but there was also a part of
feminism which sort of sought to pretend
that there are no differences between
men and women yes and then you end up in
this position right yes you're going
well there's no difference between my
women why do you need women's spaces
we're all the same right
but but we're not the same no not at all
a true feminist isn't going to say just
because you want to be treated as an
equal doesn't mean you're the same equal
and the same don't mean the same thing
right
like you can have a math equation and
it's equal but it's not the same yeah
you know what i mean yeah of course they
don't mean the same thing yeah you treat
it treat me as an equal but that doesn't
mean like respect me as the same right
pay me the same it doesn't discriminate
against me
but that doesn't mean we're the same
yeah right there's a big difference
people misconstrue those two words
so where do you think this is all going
i don't know
i honestly i think that it's coming to
an end
i really do i really do i think within
the next five years we're gonna see it
come to an end i think the new
generation like gen z was like
forget it off the rails i think i'm a
millennial we're millennials yeah i
think we i love the way we embrace that
right on the cusp we're we're clinging
desperately
millennials yeah i think i think
i mean we're biased of course but i
think we make the most sense
and i think we were
like pro lgbt actual lgbt rights like
pro-feminism and now i think it's just
gone too far to the other side and it's
starting to come back
and i think within five years i think
it's gonna i think this new generation
of kids like the younger kids are
actually gonna be more conservative
because they're looking at this [ __ ]
like like leah thomas and sports they're
looking at this as kids and they're like
that doesn't make sense like kids know
and kids are honest
and they don't sugarcoat it they know
that something is wrong so they're
seeing this happen and
do you reckon that's happening though
because if you look at what's being
taught to children at school that's well
that's that's indoctrination quite if we
didn't indoctrinate them i think right
but we are
but people are fighting against that too
in america they are so it's like i said
they're starting to fight against it so
i think it's going to continue
i think people are going to continue to
fight against it i hope so
i was not when you're actually lgbt
you don't need to be told that you're
lgbt
like you know that you're different i
knew when i was
nine years old that i was gay i didn't
know what it meant but i knew like
romantically it was a romantic thing
like i want to hold that woman's hand i
want to like right i want to be the i
want i thought i was like oh i want to
be the prince and like save the woman
from the princess blah blah
it's not a sexual thing at that age now
you're teaching kids about sex and stuff
that's not okay
no but probably got to this point how
have we got to this point where
no sorry i talked about this with blair
blair white and we've had blair on the
show as well you love her yeah she's a
great person i'm like really actually a
good person
we talked about this it's an extreme
over correction
like did gay people get treated badly
yes did black people get treated badly
yes
but now it's like it's like over
correcting
like everybody's gay right everybody is
microaggressions right
it's like it's too much it's like how
about we just meet in the middle and
that's where everybody should be right
here
but it's people it's the society over
correcting all these mistakes that
they've made and that's why we call it
woke it's like all these over
corrections like calm down
not everybody has to be gay not
everybody's trans just because they act
a little different
right
not everybody's racist
calm down
but it also gives people cachet to be
the victim and it gets them a really
easy get out of free
get out of jail free card so i'll give
an example so a couple of weeks ago i
did a test for adhd i've had and it came
out i've got adhd and that means most
people do i think right yeah yeah it's
pretty common yeah yeah and so that
means uh there's been a lot of things in
my life that i've really struggled with
right and it's very easy for me to then
go oh that's a result of this condition
therefore i can't do this i can't do
that it's everybody else's fault instead
of going well how do i fix it yeah how
do i help myself because that's
difficult it is difficult but it's the
way you have to what else are you going
to do like you can blame everybody else
but that's not actually going to help
you no no that's not self growth no
but
what for me what i find worrying about
this in ideology is that it encourages
you to see yourself as healthy as a
victim
and you know why that's popular right
now you know why the government
is condoning that or like even
prioritizing that because that means
they're going to ask the government for
help and then the government has more
power more control
let's take a communism
it's literally how communism happens i
need help i need help i don't have
anything i can't do anything the other
the only answer is the government
helping me which is interesting that it
would be happening in a country like
america because you're
very anti-communist as a nation it's not
even about anti-communists it's it's
it's the the very foundation of your
society is based on the very opposite in
terms of what you actually it's not that
you don't you anti-communism is that the
beliefs that you used to inculcate in
your society with antithesis of
communism they were about self-reliance
yes independence go get it make it
happen be free make your own mistakes by
the way the american dream right right
you can make it you can whatever you
dream you can do it if you work harder
now see that's now it's the opposite
you've got a generation of people who
are being trained to think very
differently to you yeah
so it's kind of very anti-american it is
anti-american it's sad like we have kids
nowadays like
my one of my god daughters my best
friend's daughter came home she was 12
at the time i think or 13 maybe two
years ago whatever it was she came home
and my best friend italian girl only
dates hispanic dudes she doesn't like
black dudes she doesn't like white dudes
like only like brown people she loves
brown guys and
the the kid comes home one day and calls
us white supremacists and all these
things and i'm like what is this what is
this kid learning in school like clearly
they're teaching them something and it's
like like i don't want to say the name i
was like how are you going to tell your
mom's white supremacist she only dates
white uh she only dates brown guys
your father's a brown guy
i treat you the same as i would treat
anybody else and i knew you were brown
el salvadorian since you were look like
you don't you you pass this brown like
you don't look white at all you don't
look half half-white you look brown
and nobody treats you any differently
but we're white supremacists so they're
clearly teaching these kids something
like you said why why are you white
supremacists i think we were talking
about trump or something i don't
remember because i think it was two
years ago like talk about the election
yeah you're a little one you're a white
supremacist then
and i'm like you need to stop
because you don't know what the hell
you're talking about
and i like most of the time most of the
girls i date are hispanic
so like am i like a brown supreme like
i just
we throw these labels around and we
forget how
what an awful thing that is to be right
an actual racist
exactly
there's a guy called this black black
guy that i follow on twitter do you know
him zeke the black black cop
he's great yeah and he talks about it he
talked about it in one of my videos and
he said listen my grandad actually
experienced depression and actually
experienced racism in like 1930s and 40s
whatever it was
and he's like he told me this is what he
said to me on the camera he was like he
told me do not overuse that word racist
because it diminishes what actual people
like my grandfather
like what he experienced
he's like i never use that word he's
like it's very and he calls people out
on twitter all the time he's like don't
you know he's like this is not racist
somebody asked like they liked your
haircut and you call
oh i like your braids that's racist
what
or you want to wear braids and that's
cultural appropriations racism he's like
you need to come he he calls out people
all the time i love him we need more
people like that
it's it's i know it's
it just feels it's like it's all
exhausting it really is but it just
feels like a society that's gone
mad that's what happens when you don't
have any personal responsibility because
you can even if you're going crazy you
could blame it on anything else
blame it on everything else anything
else other than yourself right
because when you were crazy back in the
day who are you going to blame
oh [ __ ] it's me
i don't want that to happen so i'm going
to like me like i went to get help for
my mental health my anxiety like i'm on
medication yeah
and it wasn't crazy but like
now
you can have all these mental illnesses
and it's like people are flaunting them
and it's like that's not
it's not something to be ashamed though
but it's also not something to be proud
of it's just it is what it is something
to work on it's something to pictures
right something to help yourself right
exactly and you people i see it in their
bio bipolar adhd and these are you know
serious conditions some more serious
than others but it's not your [ __ ]
identity it's not your identity yeah
and and marcus and i were talking about
this yesterday
they don't have an identity that's what
that's what it is because none none of
these words actually mean anything
anymore so they're just
they're grabbing at these labels and
these identities and these words that
that have no meaning
just because they can't it's like they
don't know how to develop a personality
because you know what most personalities
are developed
based on opinions of the world and these
people all think the same
so they have to have
differences in their identities to be
seen as different even though they all
think the same
but that's a great thing that this
particular ideology gives you it just
gives you a list of opinions which is
common yeah
which is a cult by the way
okay let's start let's go with that then
it's a cult
why like literally just what you said
this is what you have to believe in
order to be a part of our group and the
moment you die
and the moment you don't believe that
bye bye girl [ __ ] bye [ __ ] like that's
it you get excommunicated from the i
always use that word but it's it's like
a religion that's why i say
excommunicated it's literally like a
cult is like a religion and how have you
found this because you're obviously a
public figure in some way you know
you're on youtube you've got a big
following
so people will know who you are in the
quo i mean i this idea of the lgbt
community is is a thing i question as as
a thing to exist anyway but among
your people how do they how what kind of
like reaction do you have
like blair and i were talking about this
when i was on her her channel and
it's different now
like before we would go out and people i
love well blair differently like like
people never liked her
people
people well the lgbt people yeah but
there's like a very small subset of the
community that loves her just like but
for me it was the opposite right because
i was more on the left before you were
educating people about being gay you
were doing sex ed you were doing all
that great and then they like turned
their backs on me and they're claiming
that i turned my back on them and it's
like i've had the same opinions like for
the last 12 years but whatever except
like something on trans issues like i
became more left and then some things i
became more right depending on what new
information comes out right
um
but i think
for the most part
now
like where before people would come come
up to me and like cry and like when they
met me at like vidcon now i don't get
invited
not surprised but like now it's i
remember i was at rhode island pride and
a bunch of there was like two or three
girls together in a group and one of the
girls came up to me and she just stood
next to me didn't actually look at me
i'm not even making this up stood next
to me was like love your content
and then walked away and i was like [ __ ]
just happened like what was that because
she was afraid that other people would
see her interacting with me
that's so sad yeah yeah you can't even
like like somebody's content anymore
without being called a bigot
can't even follow them
on twitter
i know that feeling very well because i
don't know if you know this francis and
i before we started this we were in the
comedy industry in this country
and it's it's about it's it's about like
200 people or 300 people it's a small
world really a very small world where
everyone's watching each other
everyone's monitoring what everyone's
thinking what they're liking what
they're not liking terrible and i
remember i used to watch
uh
so at the time it was dave rubin's show
this was like 2016 2017 where he was
kind of going through like i'm a liberal
but i'm exploring different points of
view because he is a classic liberal so
am i yeah yeah i think
dave's evolved to think and i think he's
more squarely in the sort of on the
right box now but at the time because
everything's going so far left he's kind
of staying here so he's yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah and so at that time i found this
show very interesting because it was
kind of the journey i was going through
mentally myself yes and i would watch it
i think it would took me two years to
actually subscribe to his youtube
channel
and to like
and people are shocked when we're
talking about these kids it's like
you're a grown man you were afraid yeah
yeah my friend my friend was texting me
before he was afraid he's afraid he's a
trans guy he's afraid to talk about
these things yeah because i knew but we
both knew look at us we started the show
and all we do is we talk to people about
some of these issues just and i love the
the by the way the no filter
conversation we're having it's great
right and that's what we always wanted
this to be and we get people we just the
the guy we put out uh
two days ago is david pakman who's like
the progressive commentator on youtube
uh we had that conversation and we get
people from the left we get people in on
the right we get mostly people like you
who are just like what the [ __ ] is going
on
right because most people are there well
we are like evil right-wing uh nazi
bigots in the comedy industry in this
country right right and i don't give a
[ __ ] about that but at the time when it
mattered what people thought when they
had opportunity to limit my work my
progression in the comedy industry yeah
yeah i was terrified no of course i
don't think it's wrong to be scared it's
just sad it is they're scared terrible
it makes sense yeah and also the thing
as well is like maybe in my head i was
actually exaggerating the extent to
which i was right to be fearful but the
atmosphere is still there right and if
you but now you've you've risen above it
a little bit we have but what i'm
talking about is this girl that came up
to you imagine what it's like for her
right right because it's not even she's
in an industry where she might be forced
out or she's in a community too she's
like that's her identity that's the
whole thing right this is the people she
dates this is the people she she's good
yes right it's the whole that's their
whole livelihood and you've you like an
ariel scarcella video on youtube like
oh you follow her like you like the
tweet yeah
done sometimes i like tweets that i
don't actually like
because i wanna like it's like i you
know i wanna look like it's like a video
or something i don't have time to watch
it i'll watch it later so i like it so
it's in my like right so i can save it
yeah
it's just it's just all too much it's
too much it is it is it's also
manipulative behavior right it's it's
toxic
abusive behavior it's like an abusive
boyfriend or girlfriend looking over
your shoulder who you texting who are
you talking to why are you going out
with this person literally if you if
there was in a relationship
people would be obvious it would it's
obvious that it's abusive but it's
because it's co-workers or friendships
or just people you're following or
whatever they don't call it abusive it's
literally the same thing happening
though
but they also and this to me is a really
sinister thing because if it was just
that it's obviously disgusting awful
reprehensible blah blah blah
but they frame it as kindness yeah and
that's the thing that really
manipulation that's the manipulative
part right yeah
it's for your buddy yeah it's for your
benefit you know we have a friend of
ours who's a very good comic um who uh
during lockdown he
he was tweeting his concerns about the
impact of lockdown on people's lives and
and all of that
and another comedian these are both
black dudes by the way and this is
relevant to the story when um
he said your tweets are looking the the
optics of your tweets are very
right-wing lately he said that to you no
you said it to our friend one two three
that guy said it's another black guy
another black guy the optics of your
tweet
tweets are very right-wing lately okay
right so it's a it's basically saying
like stay on the reservation right are
you okay yeah are you okay you're gonna
be alright yeah i'm worried about you
i'm worried about it but that's not what
he's worried about no no he's trying to
go
you know you don't have these opinions
right
right yeah you know
abuse it's abuse
literally abusive behavior like textbook
psychological definition of abuse
control and manipulation
and nobody calls it out there's like
five of us that call it
said and it's the word right wing which
doesn't mean like you know when what is
the true explanation of the words right
wing it means
small government small government lower
taxes lower taxes less government
involvement right yeah less intervention
right by the government in your lives
now there are trade-offs with that
there's positives and there's negatives
and if you adhere to that particular
type of political belief ideology great
there's nothing wrong with it it's not
my view they're not my politics but they
there's a validity to it right but right
wing now doesn't mean that oh no it
doesn't mean that anymore it means this
whole other identity that they throw you
which which is funny because they're
like don't tell me how to identify but
they're throwing all these identities on
you well i've been saying this just
because you feel a certain way about
government you must be a nazi you must
be a white supremacist i've been saying
this for years you can you can be
non-binary in every way except
politically
except politically literally i've never
met i have one friend that he's not
really non-binary that's the thing he's
he's had trauma so he has dysphoria but
not like full dysphoria
um he's the only non-binary rep like
non-binary republican that i've ever met
you a conservative you'll never meet a
non-binary person other than him
that's not left-wing
like you said it perfectly yeah you can
be non-binary in every way but not
politically you can't have like me like
have an opinion that's on the left and
on the right and think of yourself as
someone in the middle no no if you've
stepped over this line here no all the
way right yeah that's it you're done
you're done [ __ ] incredible how we've
got here
it is it's sad it really is yeah
yeah
but that right wing label is really
powerful because once it sticks to you
then immediately to your right wing
which means particularly in my former
industry thank god i've left it
is
oh we can deny you opportunities
we can sideline you i know in at least
in the united states is illegal
like i don't think you're allowed to do
that right
i'd have to ask my lawyer friend yeah
yeah but i'm almost positive they cannot
deny you a job based on political
beliefs right but how do you prove it
right right exactly that's the point you
can't yeah i didn't like the way you
dressed i didn't like the way you talked
to that customer or whatever and look
we should also be grateful i mean that
happened to my friend david he got fired
because he because he was posting
political stuff online yeah but we
should also be grateful because we're
coming off as a bunch of whiners now
like
reality is
you know we have it better than half
more than half of the world i know i
know yeah we don't want to see that go
away that's why we complain about it
yeah yeah yeah and also individually
like all of us are doing okay do you
know what like we've made a principle
stand and it cost us in the short term
but in the long term i've been rewarded
for it because the truth is
these people know that this is only
going to benefit them in the short term
as well they know but they're afraid
because
the short term people only see in the
now right like what's gonna benefit
benefit me right now yeah and then okay
it's being woke they're gonna do that
but they know they don't believe in half
the [ __ ] they say
most people like you said we're in the
middle yeah we're somewhere in the
middle nobody there's not that many
extremists in this country it's really
not in the world it's really not
everyone kind of
as long as you're traveling and you're
getting to know people about the
cultures you can see from both
perspectives usually
hey francis what do you think is the
best way to advertise a business that's
easy all you need to do is spend shed
loads of cash on an advert that's going
to be promoted on a dying medium like tv
then simply sit back and watch all your
hard-earned money disappear down the
toilet what about advertising with
trigonometry why would i do that when i
can advertise on itv3 for the measly sum
of 20 grand and be watched by six people
because trigonometry now has over 350
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and gets 2 million views and
downloads a month that's right you can
place an advert with us and we'll
promote your brand on one of our
episodes your adwords will be written by
two professional comedians yeah that's
right we're hiring two professional
comedians
we make our ads funny and engaging to
the point where some people say the ads
are their favorite parts of the show
yeah we probably shouldn't admit that
mate all you need to do is contact us on
marketing at triggerpod.co.uk
that's marketing at triggerpod.co.uk
advertise with us and we'll get your
business cancelled
but the reason we have got large
following both of us is because we do
give voice to the things that people
feel that they are unable to give voice
to
in their jobs yes amongst their friends
so i mean this is a sad story i had a
friend who was a comedian and he passed
away and he was very ill and when he was
going through the late stage of his
illness we used to talk on facebook and
facebook messenger when he was getting
his treatment and he messaged me and he
said uh i love trigonometry i could
never do what you do francis because i'm
not as brave as you i went what do you
mean and he goes
i love your interviews and you know i've
got books by douglas murray and other
people but when they come around to my
house when my friends come around yeah
when my friends come around to my house
he hides her books
and when he passed away i saw everybody
talk about him and go
oh you know what a great guy this person
was how nice they were blah blah blah so
they didn't know what he really thought
they didn't know him that's so that's
like going to that's
okay in my opinion i don't want to
compare it completely
but to me that would be almost like
hiding that you're gay your whole life
and people not knowing their your truth
it's like you said coming out of the
closet yeah yeah because well that's why
they said when did you come we were
second coming out we call it coming out
as a conservative or coming out as a
non-leftist like that's what we say
because it's the truth because in the
same in in the same way that you can
lose your job in some places but not
like not a lot of places anymore you
could lose your job of your family your
your status for being gay you can also
lose those things for being conservative
that's why we call it coming out
second coming out
because it's it's stupid but you can
lose all those things again
are you conservative or are you just
non-leftist
i
like if i ask my friends that are
conservatives they would say i was
moderate
i think like i have i have some
conservative views and i have some
moderate views right
which really like just a classic liberal
i think like don't tell me how to live
my life don't don't get involved in my
and my money like don't take my money
don't tell me how to raise my kids type
of thing if i had kids right
that's like that's like a classic
liberal like if it's not hurting anybody
let me do it
classic liberal
but conservative on certain issues the
wall pro-build the wall
but i'm pro-choice like
i'm in the middle with a lot of issues
and it might change over time like it's
already changed over time but that's
normal because new information comes out
what have you changed your mind on the
most
probably economically i think i think
i've become way more conservative yeah
when you say way more conservative what
does that mean well to me like in the
states to me that means not aiding other
countries as much before we help
ourselves right like there's so many
problems in the states that we have to
fix
so many homeless kids so many homeless
people homeless veterans all these
things the cops aren't getting paid as
much and now there's all these police
brutality that like fix those issues
excuse me before you're trying to
give the ukraine 100 million dollars or
whatever it was like it's a lot more
than that more was it 400 million or
whatever was it no it's it's many many
it's like 33 billion i i i could argue
with you about that because uh american
prosperity depends on its influence and
power around the world but i i get your
point which is uh i think your point
broadly is the united states should make
sure to look after its own citizens
right before it does anything that's the
point right yeah that's the fine
challenge i understand economically yes
it it needs to be controlled it needs to
control the things to right i get that
yeah
america consumes overwhelming hugely
disproportionate amount of the world's
resources right right as do we here in
the uk and part of the reason for that
is you have control over the whole world
and that's where you know the ukraine
thing is a bit more complex than that
but i know exactly what you're saying
you know what i'm trying to say i know
i'm not trying to like comment on the uk
because i don't understand i haven't
made a video about it because there's no
way i can actually understand about it
that's why i was asking it's just
curious because and this is the thing
that will be people like go oh she
she doesn't
we're human beings we're going through
life and we're trying to work things out
and this is not your area of expertise
no right so i i don't feel any sort of
like oh my gosh you said this about it
at all but i i think i hear what you're
saying which is
a country should look after its own
people yes first especially because
we're the ones that paid the taxes and
stuff right like if you're paying more
taxes especially yeah why why are all
these immigrants coming in and get like
i saw this firsthand from living born
and raised in new york
and it's funny like falling funnily
enough i know a lot of people say oh
it's the black people it's literally not
black people that are taking advantage
of this i don't know you don't want to
hear this but
it's it's a lot of it's a lot of chinese
people are russian people in in new york
that are taking advantage of like social
security and stuff like that that are
not from there
that have more they had more benefits
than i did as an american citizen
more health benefits like i had to go
the doctor i had to pay 300 for a visit
sometimes they got for free yeah so to
me i was i was growing up i'm thinking
that's not fair
they just come to this country and get
all these and again economically i don't
know how it works exactly but i know it
doesn't seem fair
so like what where is that coming from
yeah that makes a lot of issues it's a
lot of issues but this is these are
things that the left don't want to
discuss right because when it comes to
immigration
they want a particular narrative that
they all adhere to they don't want to
actually talk about the complexities of
what it means to have a large immigrant
population coming in and as with all of
these things there are numerous benefits
and there are negatives there are
trade-offs right but they're not
prepared to have an honest discussion
about that no
because they want to be called bigots
and racists
they're afraid of their own people
like it like they're they're miserable
people if you look at them
like we made a joke about this a while
ago who was it a friend of mine and i
like conservatives literally are like
more attractive
i know that sounds stupid to say but for
the most part it's true not because
they're actually more attractive like
physically or something but because the
energy
like liberals are all like like not
liberals leftists
are always angry
about something they're always miserable
like that's not an attractive quality to
have
so
i think you're talking about the
activists in particular people that we
that we see right right that's what i
mean
yeah yeah i have well i have friends i
have a friend uh who's like uh pro up
and borders pro like 100
renewable energy all of this stuff that
doesn't practically work right and it
and he's a really lovely guy
and when when you have a conversation
with him he's like yeah i know it
doesn't work i know it's not practical
but i just feel good you know i just
yeah i just feel good thinking about it
you know i just i just have a difference
i just hope we lived in a world where we
could have open borders and i just hope
we lived in a way that would be great
but that's not how the world is no right
and that's always going to be the
tension and look by the way there are
points in history realistic versus
idealism yeah but there are points in
history where you the the conservative
side of things it gets a little bit too
stuck in its own ways and you need
people who have a bigger vision to come
and just unstuff the whole place a
little bit you know yes
and so this is which are people like me
right and blair we're like by the way
like come a little bit like the the
right has come a little bit more left
like yeah
but the left went far like yeah exactly
like it went too much but this this is
the point this is why i was saying it's
people like you and us because like the
the people i used to watch growing up as
comics were bill hicks and george carlin
these were two lefties
massive lefties but they were talking
about political correctness they were
talking about free speech right they
just didn't want a massive government
telling them what they can't and can't
say and at the time it was the right the
religious right that was going you can't
say this you can't joke about jesus you
can't do this we talk about that and
they were pushing against it they were
pushing against the authorities
well the left in america was what the
60s the hippies yeah don't tell me i
live my life
that's not what the left is now left is
like do whatever they tell you to do
yeah listen to the government yeah if
you're it's like the opposite of what it
used to be even in the 90s
do you know where they were they had
bangers and stuff like that like the emo
kids they were the leftists
and they're still the leftist but
they believe in something different now
where the left really lost me was just i
couldn't believe how authoritarian they
are particularly when it came to covid
they just like lock everything down shut
it shut it shut it shut it shut it let's
never open again let's live and you're
going what the
what's going on
what's genuinely what's going on it's
not
i i
i think they've gotten to a point where
they're just so scared to do anything
that's
not seen as appropriate
do you think that's true too
do you know for people that are here
look because leftists here are crazy too
right yeah yeah yeah
but and that's your fault america's
fault do you think we've influenced this
yeah
oh i don't know well we just
i don't know i can't tell you
the egg like
western culture is really exported
american culture yeah yeah a lot of the
time we we we watch your moments i'm
sorry that we did that yeah yeah we
watch your movies we listen to your
podcasts we you know all of that yeah
yeah the cultural so we get we listen to
your music a lot all the time we want
reparations
[Laughter]
for all of this [ __ ]
that's what we want but that's why it's
the anglo-sphere yeah because it because
it's it's coming out of american
cultural institutions and academia and
twitter and all of that [ __ ] it's coming
from america and we're all going oh
give it to me right you know that's
where it's coming from
and so that's why people like us like
francis and i are not really that
interested in american politics and so
if i mean i've always paid attention to
it but you have to pay attention because
you have to critique it and then yeah
because we have to see what's coming
what's the next thing right you have to
right yeah you know right that makes
sense
that's that's what and so we're all kind
of just like getting all the [ __ ] and so
we're all part of your culture war now
oh [ __ ]
canada i'm kind of i don't know canada
kind of
is even further left than we are right
like they had pro they were against free
speech
since like 2013 or something like if you
misgendered somebody or whatever it was
yeah well that's how jail are good again
that's how jordan peterson became right
that's exactly that's how he that's how
he rose to fame because he would not it
wasn't like he didn't want to be nice to
these trans people it's like you could
not take away my freedom of speech
that's really what that argument was
about but of course they misconstrued it
and made it about trans right yeah it's
like no that's not what this is when was
the moment where you thought
no i'm not really on board with this
train
oh my god
when they told me i had to suck dick
honestly it was that simple for me who
told you to suck dick a lot of people
a lot of a lot of people claiming to be
lesbians
because they were trans act because they
were trans-inclusive lesbians
like that was like the moment where i
was like okay this is just homophobia
and it's fine like how did we get here
how did how did
how is how are supposed to these
supposed people that are queer activists
literally against what homosexuality is
so same sex attractions you said
like the genitals apparently mean
nothing to these people it's like the
generals which literally things that you
have sex with
me nothing
that was what like really started red
pilling me
and then my friend showed me this
documentary i don't want to say it on
camera but
she showed me this documentary and i was
like holy crap and now that was three
years ago two and a half years ago and
now things that were said two and a half
years ago are coming true that were said
in the documentary so now i believe
everything that said
like things about prince andrew and
stuff like that were talked about two
years ago
and then like would the queen take away
his
his status and whatever it was
last sneaky let me just say
there's a lot of like underground sneaky
stuff
that's happening and it's all
somehow most of it's because most of it
is on not all of it because there's some
conservatives that are like you know
secretly gay and pedophiles or both or
whatever no you can't be both you know
what i mean they're secretly gay or
they're pedophiles and they won't you
know or but most of these people are
like
more progressive
like most of these people that are that
are
that have these sneaky side lives
or
you know what i'm trying to say i know
we're trying a lot of them i'm thinking
it through i don't know how true it
depends on again it depends on the time
period like
uh we've had a lot of historical uh like
pedophilic
abuses revealed in this country in the
last 10 15 years
and a lot of those people were very much
with the establishment which would have
been more conservative at the time yeah
so i think it just depends on who has
power actually maybe i think so it kind
of depends if you are in power you can
get away with [ __ ] basically right and
there's nonsense as we call them on on
all sides yeah of course yeah just i
guess it just happens that in the states
right now it's more progressively yeah
so i think it's probably yeah i don't
think being progressive makes you a
paedophile no no no no no no of course
not that's why i said there's some
conservatives too i just
that will get views yeah it will do
incredibly progresses are pedophile
so good
that would be a great time i mean the
progressives believe in like aged
what do you call it
marcus what was it age regression and
like all these like you could be age
fluid so well that's the next thing
isn't it if you can be a different sex
why can't you be a different age
what a great world we live in so i uh so
what's your plan with with your youtube
channel are you gonna is this what
you're gonna continue to focus on or i
think so do you hope this is [ __ ] is
over so you can go back to talking about
sex headlines no i like this is job
security for me
it's keeping me working
it's true
it's true it's true because beforehand
it was job security too because it was
all these all these people on the right
this was years ago
on the right hating us for being gay too
and now people on the left hate me for
being gay it's the same [ __ ]
just coming from a different side it's
coming from a woke perspective like we
mean this because we're trying to help
you isn't that what the christians and
catholics and
they would say the same [ __ ] yeah so
it's just coming from the other side we
don't want you to be a racist we don't
want you to be transphobic so we're just
doing this to help you
it's now infected corporations that's
the that's the amazing thing yeah but
when you go woke you go broke
you know that right like all these
companies that are going woke are losing
money yeah yeah
disney
netflix coke
remember what happened with coke
like you don't remember what happened
with coke in atlanta they're based in
atlanta i think
it was like there was like a woke racist
anti-white racist training or whatever
that went viral you don't remember that
the coke of pepsi it was called coke
yeah yeah yeah yeah
their stocks went down right they lost a
lot of money a lot of support a lot of
people were giving them [ __ ]
like rightfully so they were telling
people how to how to be less white i
remember this now yeah but how does it
even make sense how can you be less
white like my skin didn't change any
color yeah still white yeah unless they
go out in the sun but this is this is
what they've done is it defines
whiteness as being as being bad state of
mind right and therefore if you change
the way you think
then you become less white and then
you're you're observed of your many
senses exactly because the sin of
whiteness has been right wiped away
which is the opposite of what is reality
right can't be less white or less black
you just are yeah but this is going back
to that rachel dollars i'll comment i
watched the documentary on rachel
dolezal and she was and she was in the
university was it a university that she
was in or she came to do a talk about uh
black studies or something along those
lines
and this was after she was outed and
this student stood up and went you have
no right to call yourself black i'm like
correct right and then she went you
haven't earned the right to be black i'm
like what
you haven't earned the right that's not
an earned right it's just it is yeah
it's in existence
and it's so bizarre but i think it comes
back to that point that i made about the
the the bar person at the theater
at one of our live shows where it's
about opting out of things and opting
into things and and i think what people
which is so easy these days because you
don't even have to do anything to
identify something right you could just
say it and you have to believe it and
also i think the more lives move online
the the more
online you are less constrained by the
parameters of reality like you could
start a a twitter account or even just
to some extent a youtube channel
in which nobody knows what you look like
so you could be like i could be like a
black lesbian on twitter
and it it costs nothing
there's nothing i have to do i'm not
constrained by my body i'm not
constrained by my genetics i'm not
constrained by anything right and i
think the more the online world becomes
the world
and the more people are
are persuaded that you can sort of
customize your experience of life by you
know thinking and having identities the
more i think you will see people who are
just opting out of reality which is what
i think is happening you know so i i'm
very hopeful that the pushback that
you're talking about is coming although
as always with pushbacks when the
pendulum swings back
it's going to go the other way again and
you know i hope it does it's going to
over swing it always does yeah it's
going to overswing and you talk about it
yourself over the correction of it
yeah the acceptance of lgbt people is
going down because it's just become too
much yeah right instead of just going
hey can we just all get on with each
other and not treat people differently
because of who they are it's now sucked
to dig bigger yeah right yes and people
don't want to suck the dick
don't want
not a fan
you know i i tried touching one i had to
on a video it's on youtube and i just i
even had difficulty doing that i'm not
gonna lie
what is that i'm not a fan yeah it's
that's what's happening but good news
for us is that it's still happening so
we get to make more videos about it yeah
yeah
ain't that the truth it well
i i but
if it came to a toss-up between
you know
society not going down the drain yeah i
know i know
we all being you know and it's a joke
i'm being facetious yeah of course we
all are we don't want the world going to
[ __ ] just like
money but also i think you and we
there's other [ __ ] we want to talk about
yeah exactly when we started out we were
and still even now regularly we
interview evolutionary psychologists
evolutionary biologists we want to
understand how people work why are men
different why are brains you had colin
on the show uh colin yeah yeah we've had
but again we have to talk to him about
[ __ ] trans i know i i want to talk to
him about actual [ __ ] right but we got
it because we got can you please prove
to us that men are different from women
because some people like
and he proves it he's still a bigot
right yeah why can't we just like i'm
i'm i'm more interested in like
understanding each other like why do
women behave in this way generally and
why do men behave in this way and how
can we connect better and how to
coexist and what about like personal
growth and personal development how do
you overcome trauma how do you like yeah
you know talk about these deeper
conversations
yeah like about you know i i want to get
on somebody who's been on a journey
through a difficult journey in their
life and and learn from them how do you
make your life better how do you help
people how do you become more fulfilled
instead i've got to talk about sucking
dicks
it always comes back to sucking dick
it doesn't always come back with me it
really does yeah yeah it's how things
get done
i don't even know what that means i
don't know either but it made sense yeah
yeah yeah
you know what i mean
i don't want to be talking about the
culture war i don't want to be 50 years
old and talking about the culture war
yeah to me can you imagine that we're
still in the second season you're just
sitting
but here's the thing that worries me
we're talking about things that are
genuinely nuts
yeah objectively mental right
and this is where we are now and if you
think about progressivism or what the
the clue is in the word is progress
you're progressing somewhere which makes
me worried about it it's great branding
by the way incredible brand great
branding nobody wants to because even
could the word conservative sounds kind
of like yeah
it does it does it does it's really i
listen i went to school and i studied
advertising great branding the
progressive movement has terrible
ideology yeah great branding incredible
conservative it's like what conservative
sounds like we're shutting you out yeah
we're conservative and you're boring
you're tedious
you just do missionary that's that's
what conservatives do you know what i
mean don't look each other in the eye
and get the act done and let's hope for
a better whole like juice i feel like
we're just we're just giving away our
personal life here basically
but
true
but i hope not i'm not but but
that's that's throwing me for a loop but
the thing that worries me is
where are we progressing to right where
are we going if in 2022 we're doing this
we're doing this [ __ ]
you know leah thomas i'm a woman dive in
smash all the female swimmers right
where where were we going to be in five
years yeah well you think it's actually
going to i think it's i think it's
starting to come back around yeah yeah
yeah yeah well that's why i say you know
i hope we don't throw the baby out with
the bath water right and i think that's
really important to say yeah because
you're starting to see like like just
like keep the good stuff tossed the best
right like we figured we're figuring it
out you don't have to toss all the good
stuff out right now all the good stuff
with the bad stuff yeah well exactly
because right i i it worries me that
like we're gonna get to a position it's
like oh the rainbow people yeah they're
all they're all crazy yeah yeah that's
what i'm worried about too why do you
think people like me and blair and buck
and marcus talk about these things
because we don't we we're damage control
we're literally the damage control of
the gay community
i think of the lgbt community and the
thing that i'm starting to see is people
just being openly hateful now of trans
people and going oh yeah these are the
types of people this is what they're
doing to our kids i'm like no no no
don't go there right please don't go
there defenseman it's a defense
mechanism and it's understandable
because they they see like an end they
they want to see a very specific enemy
but that's not but it's going to be the
trans people and other people who suffer
as a result that's exactly
we have been telling them for five years
now for five years i've been making
videos about like trans issues
i didn't come out as like a more
conservative person until two years ago
but since 2015 i've been talking about
trans stuff
and and basically telling people like
you need to calm down because you're
making it and and it's been proven i'm
i've been i don't want to be right but
i'm right
lower and lower every year our
acceptance rate yeah because of those
people not because of me
not because of me we got my generation
of gay people got gay rights we got gay
marriage
these these this new generation this
whole everybody could be queer
thing
whatever that is no it doesn't even mean
anything
that's when it started going downhill
for us
so
i don't want to be right i hate being
right in this case it's not about like
hopefully you're right about the
pendulum at least right i hope so and
then and then we'll be sitting here
pissing off all the people that watch us
now going guys guys slow down don't go
crazy right we've got to stay in the
sensible middle yes that's what will
happen i think so best case scenario yes
best case scenario scenario
yeah
and
that's it yeah i think i think that's a
good note to end
but we do have so a lot of questions
from our audience for locals only which
we'll ask in a sec okay but we forgot to
warn you about this but you'll have an
answer the last question we always ask
is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that you
think we really should be
ooh
i don't know how to answer that yeah the
one thing that we should be talking
about that we're not yeah
i mean i talk about everything i feel
like
okay i i guess you could i think we need
to talk more about
pedophiles in in people people of power
i really do because there's a lot of
them and i don't think anyone's covering
it we are yeah okay on raw three nights
a week we just talked about peter
that's it there you go non-spanter
non-spanta as we call it yeah nance is a
great word by the way yeah what is it
it's a british for pedophile but it sort
of sounds less offensive yeah
don't don't make it listen don't be
calling them maps and [ __ ] like no no
mono attracted pedophiles no no don't
like let's not let's not do it yet no no
no there's no plans to do that yeah
anyway we need to talk more about
pedophiles yeah and on that note yeah on
that note
we are going to ask ariel a couple of
questions from you for you for locals in
a second but thank you so much for
watching we hope you've enjoyed it we
know you've enjoyed it and we'll see you
very soon with another brilliant episode
like this one oral show where we talk
all about them pedos
7 p.m uk time and for those of you like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
how do we work with those who are
anti-lgbtq
plus for religious reasons
[Music]
you